Whitney Carson's father-in-law Kevin
McCallister died on Thursday night at
the age of 57 after battling cancer for
two years
the Dancing with the Stars pros shared
the sad news on Instagram posting this
pic with Kevin and her husband Carson
writing in part quote we are so grateful
for the time we've had with him on this
earth and we know he's in a better place
until we meet again just last weekend
the 24 year old and her family threw a
birthday party for Kevin and documented
the celebration on Instagram a day
earlier the dancer shared this pic along
with an emotional update on his health
quote we are devastated to share that
Kevin's body is no longer able to
tolerate treatment
he's on hospice and we are just
cherishing every moment we have with him
in December Whitney announced that she
would be pulling out of the Dancing with
the Stars winter tour to be by her
husband's side during this difficult
time and just last week she shared a
heartwarming video of Kevin spending
time with his family
writing enjoying all the time we get
with him